hello
oh my god it's the hulk you got my
favorite color one oh thank you first of
all you are the hulk yeah your hands
what the heck
iconic
bigger character of all time 40 years
later three generations it's insane you
really open the doors for people like
arnold
yes everybody because back then you'd
have you'd have steve just alone arnold
doing rainbow i was the first one that
uh the body was
able to
to transplant into the film industry
because back then people kind of
stereotype but now you see like hugh
jackman but i bet everybody wants to be
booked
but i'm still here because 40 years
later i've done over 40 films i've done
six tv series but everybody loves the
hulk
which is wonderful oh it's so wonderful
is there a chance we could see you maybe
like in the mcu at some point working on
it i'd love to be part of the marvel
universe come back with a new character
yeah
like you're just in the flesh you are
all that so i want to see it
happen five years i've done 90 episodes
yeah there were even today when you
watched the show every show had a laser
compelling message about life it's
beautiful it wasn't nothing to do with
blood sexual violence it was healthy
yeah
what is your first memory of watching
the godfather
wow i remember my friends were talking
about it at the end there was a group of
friends they kept talking about the
opening scene i remember when i went to
see it because even though i had a
hearing aid problem back then i remember
just watching the acting the intensity
the mafia uh how uh you know especially
uh the loyalty and the disability the
fighting the shooting wow i mean it just
i ended up watching it 500 more times
i'm a big fan of it too
in creating the offer was there one
thing that like really surprised you
or how the movie got made all these
characters coming together because that
once people see this the series they
should watch the car farther again they
can see what a better understanding of
the character
enjoy it yes it was so nice to meet you
so cool
i try
you